[Applause]
a little cowboy boot kind of thing going
i'm going to
wear this for you i feel like i will
wear that tomorrow i know i would wear
that i'm like that's i know switch i
literally can't ask myself looked at me
and i walked in and she was like do you
want to go like comfortable and i was
like please
you know like days you're just tired and
you're like i don't feel like sucking in
um so
it's nice to see y'all it's so funny
because we're neighbors i never see you
my daughter did and you mentioned
something about a playdate and she will
not stop talking about i was like she
was being nice oh my god i was like no i
know but she don't like your coffees she
is like everything and i was like ben
you ordered all this stuff but all the
money that we drink and then i said
kelly i was like oh god i know and i
usually order it for like people that
come in the morning to be like nice to
like help with the kids like everything
and literally like any target orders
amazon like coffee orders they all go to
your house
people have a hard time with my address
i've opened your sinks and then okay
saddest part because i'm renovating
you're renovating so there were i opened
four big boxes so four sinks and i was
like
[Laughter]
did i order six it wasn't that like
these aren't mine i had to be like
was i was this like one o'clock on a
unisom and did i
kelly i was like oh for god's sake i
don't know why people have a hard time
with my address but whatever
[Music]
you